we may have talked a lot about the
designs of tesla cyber truck since it is
impossible not to be fascinated by this
incredible breakthrough it is now
necessary to concentrate on the
manufacturing revolution brought about
by tesla when it comes to grand
innovative ideas few can compete with
tesla in the world of science and
technology from colonizing mars to
developing the hyperloop few can match
tesla's accomplishments elon musk's
vision for tesla has placed a strong
emphasis on the company's production
operations it has been reported that
tesla is now producing the model y with
a giant rear underbody that used to be
made of 70 parts this is very possible
due to tesla's first gigapress which was
installed at the fremont factory and put
in operation last year the gigapress is
the first of its kind and is produced by
idra group in italy it has a clamping
force of 55 000 to 61 000 kilonewton the
gigapress holds a lot of possibilities
for the electric vehicle industry it has
often been said that for musk and
therefore for tesla the manufacturing
process is equally important as what is
being manufactured in this view of
things revolutionizing the manufacturing
process isn't just a means for creating
better products but a crucial priority
in itself so let's look at the cutting
edge manufacturing revolution at tesla
the gigapress is one of them let's
examine its origins impacts and future
even though tesla's production process
seems groundbreaking some do not fully
believe in its efficacy there have
always been critics who take everything
musk claims with a grain of salt
internal reports from tesla itself have
sometimes been at odds with musk's
claims but even if musk's grand
ambitions have led or fallen short in
the past it doesn't seem that the
manufacturing revolution of tesla is
bound for that road the gigapress
signals a deep evolution in the body of
cars doors and protection improving
aesthetics and modularity this gigapress
is described as the biggest casting
press machine in the world and tesla is
trying to deploy as many as they can
production of larger vehicles this giant
machine will be used for the production
of chassis components of larger vehicles
vehicles such as pickup trucks full
electric lightweight goods vehicles and
suvs it is a maestro and not only shows
the capabilities of edra's technical
superiority but also validates the many
years of hard work that have gone into
realizing the tesla manufacturing
project production of better exoskeleton
with the gigapress the entire
exoskeleton of the cyber truck will be
made out of a single piece of sheet
metal this is a remarkable feat when
compared with legacy automakers who
still assemble thousands of parts to
make one complete vehicle according to
elon musk the gigapress gives tesla the
ability to do with one machine what
would have previously been done with
over 300 robots removing the variable of
having to perfectly line up many
different parts provides for a more
consistent chassis and more reliability
in the production lines this also lets
tesla make the cyber truck much more
affordable than its contemporaries and
demands can also be met swiftly a change
to how cars are made tesla's
manufacturing revolution may completely
change the way automobiles and other
products are being made in building
vehicles the gigapress has caused tesla
to shift away from the way cars have
been made for years the previous ways
are mostly variations of the toyota
production system and they go towards a
more vertically integrated system a
boost for tesla products so what is
tesla making with all of these
manufacturing innovations in place with
the gigapress tesla reportedly has
several exciting projects lined up for
the future musk has confirmed that a
more affordable and compact electric car
costing just 25 000 is also in the works
this could open up the market even more
and succeed in strengthening tesla's
hold on the electronic vehicle industry
another project that could benefit from
the gigapress innovation is the spread
of tesla electric vehicles tesla
restaurants movie theaters and other
facilities these are being planned to be
built around tesla supercharging
stations the highest volume of battery
plants the original tesla gigafactory in
nevada that has a gigapress produces
electric motors and battery packs for
tesla's model 3 electric cars it is the
highest volume battery plant in the
world even though it began production
back in 2016 it is said that gigan
nevada is only 30 complete and when
completed it will be the biggest factory
in the world more employment tesla's
fremont factory is its oldest location
and even with the widespread expansion
of the gigapress it is still the most
active versatile and central hub of
operations it employs more than 10 000
employees and manufactures all models of
electric cars that tesla has in the
market additive manufacturing although
it is still not economically feasible to
use 3d printing for car parts it may
soon be so job listings for giga nevada
show that tesla is looking for employees
with additive manufacturing
specializations so they can work with
gigapress tesla's manufacturing
revolution is characterized by the use
of technology using ai for automation
robots large-scale die-casting additive
manufacturing and bold use of new and
innovative ideas increased production
with our giant casting machine we are
literally trying to make full-size cars
in the same way that toy cars are made
musk said this in a tweet in january the
way tesla uses die casting has been
likened to 3d printing in the same way
small components and prototypes can be
3d printed an entire car chassis can be
made this concept was also supported by
ventures like the acquisition of perbx a
company that designs and builds the kind
of machinery that tesla needed highly
automated machinery capable of large
volume large velocity production they
have cycle time of around 90 seconds
which ultimately results in a production
rate of around 1 000 castings per day
per machine tesla's gigapress is so
innovative because the ability to
produce an entire rear casting with one
machine eliminates quality issues as
well as complexity and time
groundbreaking operations tesla's die
casting operations using the gigapress
are perhaps the most groundbreaking of
their production processes when talking
about tesla's gigacasting methods musk
has said that for the model y it gives
40 savings of rear underbody cost and
makes the car with 79 fewer parts
creating the entire rear body as a
single piece out of a special aluminum
alloy the gigapress lives up to its name
its physical footprint is formidable
measuring 20 meters by 7.5 meters by 6
meters it also weighs a whopping 430
tons or about 5 space shuttles so
massive is a gigapress that it takes up
to 24 flatbed trucks to transport its
components the more gigapress the more
tesla gigafactories needless to say the
gigapress is poised to become a key part
of tesla's gigafactories from now on as
tesla rolls out its single piece cast
design for the vehicles in its lineup
the company's platoon of gigapress
machines will likely play an even bigger
role this role will likely become
prominent later in the year
gigafactories are massive scale
production facilities of tesla that are
characterized by features like high
volume and velocity of manufacturing
high degree of automation specificity of
products and running on renewables musk
first coined the term in 2013 and said
that it would produce outputs similar to
all lithium-ion production in the world
in one factory some of the existing
gigafactories are giga new york
gigafactory in buffalo new york produces
products for the generation and storage
of solar energy this facility is key to
maintaining tesla's focus on a
sustainable and renewable future giga
shanghai assembly of tesla's cars for
distribution in china takes place in
gigafactory 3 in shanghai china
established in 2018 plans to expand the
plant are underway and currently the
factory produces around 500 000 units
annually gigatexas the other plan
gigafactory is gigafactory 5 or
gigatexas musk has reportedly said that
once complete this facility will be an
ecological paradise as elon musk has
said the competitive strength of tesla
long term is not going to be the car
it's going to be the factory we can see
this is happening already according to
musk the gigapress is the machine that
creates machines an idea that he has
frequently discussed originally inspired
by musk's ambition to increase the
density of products as well as the
velocity with which cars leave factories
this vision has evolved through time
furthermore it is necessary to place a
greater emphasis on the efficiency
benefits that can be realized by
enhancing the manufacturing process to
put it another way shifting the emphasis
away from enhancing the machine and
toward improving the machine that makes
the machines is quite important no doubt
the gigapress is the machine that makes
the machines you just have to accept
that the gigapress is shaping up to be
one of tesla's innovations in the
emerging electric vehicle sector and if
recent comments from the company that
produces the gigapress are by any
indication true it appears that tesla
may be on track to end 2021 with over 10
of the gigapress machines deployed in
its production facilities